[Music]
thank you
we have had an increased presence of the
public watching those drop boxes and
over the weekend there were armed
individuals who were outside of that
those of one of the drop boxes
it's
[Music]
it's weird I I don't know I've already
filled out my ballot so I'm not going to
change who I voted for
um
but yeah if I was aware of guns I might
not have come down here
[Music]
thank you
the climate around the election in
Arizona is extremely tense it's very
polarized and it really should not be
right I mean elections in our country
and of course in Arizona
are supposed to be a you know part of
the democratic process very bureaucratic
[Music]
foreign
resources just to give people confidence
that they can cast a vote safely and
that is absurd it's absurd to think that
any individual can go to a a vote box
and drop their their ballot but you
can't go to a polling site and not be
harassed that you you can't cash your
vote and at the conclusion see an
election and of confidence that the
outcomes are just
thank you
foreign
[Music]